[Music]
hey gq i'm zane i'm a hair colorist in
new york city and i work out of a studio
called saturn 16.
today we're going to recreate maluma's
blonde mohawk hairstyle
let's meet our client
hi
nice to meet you victor nice to meet you
if you want to take a seat thank you
so let's take a look at some of maluma's
most iconic hairstyles
so young maluma march 2017 he's looking
pretty clean
it's a simple haircut in 2018 he starts
experimenting with color he's got some
bleach ombre type look it's a little bit
grown out it looks organic and then in
2019 he starts having the close cropped
barbered hairstyles that's cool and then
in 2020 he starts to do some more
fashion colors we see the pink
and then also the designs on the sides
of his head it's a little bit more
experimental
more bold in spring 2021
he's sporting a mohawk it's blonde it's
maybe the most extreme cut he's had so
far in the series we've looked at it's
like a twist on a classic mohawk it's
kind of shaved down on the sides but
it's still pretty wide kind of like a
very accentuated
but
clean not too punk mohawk it's giving
sexy but reserved i like it yeah yeah
it's nice let's do it have you ever
colored your hair before
i bleached my hair like two years ago
and it got orange you did it yourself
yes i did by myself that's usually what
happens you hear
so are you ready to do something a
little bit more fun yes let's do it
before we start the coloring we'll start
off with a fresh cut and shape
step two is going to be bleaching the
hair step three will tone the hair which
helps to take out any of the yellow
tones that'll be left over
step four finishing touches so let's get
started let's do it
hey gq my name is richard mendoza i'm a
barber here in new york city hey victor
you ready i'm about to change you up
this maluma haircut it's undercut here
and a faux hawk in the back we're going
to go a little short in the front to the
back it's going to give you
a nice slick wild style look i like are
you ready to do it yes let's get this on
yeah so i'm starting the sides making
sure i get a nice wide mohawk i'm using
the clip number two
i'm just going down
and cleaning up so we're going to give
you a deep hard line shape on the side
i'm glad you picked this look
this is definitely gonna change you up
i'm gonna go big yeah
all right so i'm giving you um a little
fade over here
but the other side i want to do like a
half and maybe i could throw a little
bit of a
little line design it'll look fire and
enhance your haircut even more
[Music]
have you had a design on the side of
your head no never it really expressed
yourself you know people go out there
having like zigzags or three slashing
the line now today everyone's just
trending now you see maluma doing it
alvin doing it that bunny is doing it
so i'm leaving this side a little longer
right now i'm doing a 0.5 clip and i'm
just brushing it through
making sure there's no hair popping out
if i ever want to do this design again
yeah what's the name of it um usually
people just call it like can i get the z
line
z like a z
or usually you just take a picture and
show your barber yeah that's easier can
i get this one
[Music]
okay you can see a nice little blend
that looks nice i'm just gonna blend
your beard a little bit you have a good
length beard so i think it goes well
maluma has it real short but i'm gonna
give you a little length because i like
i like a little hang on the sides it
doesn't have to be a sharp line when the
hair color follows through you'll see
that it's overlapping
i call this the scissor walk i'm just
walking just i'm gliding my scissor
through his hair
so what can i do at home to
to maintain this just watch it grow put
products play with it
any trimmer you have you just you know
continue to clean up the edges of the
sides but let it just rock in action
all right victor we are done we have a
nice little shift little texture on the
top a nice little heart shaped side
and you got a cool little design that
you're going to be surprised that you're
like
[Music]
right now there's a very clear line of
delineation where we're trying to bleach
and where it's shaved and we don't want
to get any lightening product on so i'm
going to cover this in protective base
whenever i have anybody in my chair
i kind of look at it as a collaboration
like i'm leaving my ego
at
the door because this is about your head
and it's not about mine
[Music]
i'm gonna start in the back because it
tends to develop slower i'm gonna go
around the perimeter in the back
and then once i move to the front i'll
do that again just to minimize any kind
of bleeding your body heat is helping
the hair to develop quicker we try to do
it as quickly as possible right now i'm
just trying to outline my section so i
can zip through
when we finish bleaching your hair what
we're trying to get to is a level 10
which is a pale yellow
from there we can
tone out that yellow and get you to
maluma's platinum blonde how are you
feeling right now
a little bit tingly
okay it's not spicy yet
okay now i'm going to go around the
perimeter up here too
this is where we don't want to hit any
of the designs but because rich left a
negative
space line it should be easier to manage
[Music]
as you guys can see the back of victor's
hair is already lightening we
are now covering
the front which will develop faster
because there's more heat coming from
the top of your head
level one is like the black is black
like blue black almost no one has
hair that dark my hair it looks pretty
black but it's a level three what we're
trying to get victor to is a level 10 so
what i'll do
once we start getting closer to that is
kind of wipe some of the bleach away to
see what kind of color we're at
in terms of what we've bleached out
our rule of thumb is that we're looking
for the inside of a banana
that's a level 10.
are you excited yeah he's very excited
i'm very curious to see the result it's
so cool that you can't see anything i
love that
you're already at like a level eight
which is beautiful you're right on track
and i'm just gonna put a cap on to kind
of have the
heat develop evenly all around
so it's been 45 minutes and we've rinsed
the bleach out of victor's hair we did a
light shampoo and condition to get all
the bleach out and also to
make the porosity of the hair even
so when we apply the toner it'll be an
even application
[Music]
so the toner is done being applied we're
going to set a timer for 10 minutes and
then go wash out
so we're going to put a little bit of
verb ghost oil in your hair just to
condition it since we
just did so much to your hair we want to
close the cuticle a little bit the toner
did that already but
i just want there to be a little bit of
oil in your hair
now i'm just going to take a little bit
of the stavenous shine wax and emulsify
it in my hands and just work it through
you don't need very much you don't want
the hair to be greasy you just kind of
want to have that playful tussle
so now we've toned it to this beautiful
ashy silvery blonde similar to maluma's
photo but as you can see he has some
roots we're gonna have that for victor
in
one to two weeks depending on how fast
his hair grows and then there will be
that
kind of grown-in look
okay victor are you ready for the final
reveal yes yeah
hell yeah
here we go
whoa
oh my god
nice i love it
let's see
it's good
[Music]
so in order to maintain this like
beautiful
ashy blonde i suggest that you get some
purple shampoo a deep conditioning mask
once or twice a week to maintain the
integrity of your hair but other than
that get some cool pomade or something
to put some texture in your hair so it
can
move nicely but stay in place and then
you're good thank you very much thank
you i love it
it was so much fun thank you
thanks for watching today's episode of
make me look like i think victor pulled
it off great i'll see you next time
[Music]